[Applaudissements]
alors pour la première fois et à mon
avis la dernière fois je vais il dit
bonjour à tous et bienvenue à nantes
touche pas à mon j'ai failli à temps
inquiétez pas en france jeudi dernier
oui c'est jeudi dernier sert il nous a
dit qu'il serait pas là aujourd'hui il a
cherché qui pourrait le remplacer
alors il a trouvé le summum avec bernard
bas à prendre ou à laisser vous et moi
ou de tarifs série réussit le tour de
force à faire que je suis encore plus
stressé quand il n'est pas là que quand
il est là ce qui est quand même
ah mais non d'ailleurs non ça va pas ça
ne va pas voilà regarde là bas voilà
donc la
et pour les
samia cuites importées ça tient de cyril
je le donne voilà maintenant tu peux te
remettre à l'endroit
parce que voilà à 15 ans je répète était
heureuse de l'avoir derrière mais là je
mets mais si ça commence bien
je vais quand même voir qui a profité de
l'absence de série pour se faire porter
pâle benjamin il est là mais c'est parce
qu'ils espèrent à juste titre que je
vais me vautrer est là parce que
nathalie c'est une bonne personne
voilà ça l'a marqué mais jean-michel
mais jean-michel jean-michel bas on a
presque le même âge je sais bien que
fait beaucoup d'efforts mais oui mais tu
vois ça faye et wap 1,3 à je suis arrivé
avant donc ils sont dit qu'elle veut
c'est des mois à ma kelly kelly je
compte sur toi tu veux à mon secours dès
que tu peux je ne parle même pas je
t'aime mais je te parle même pas
géraldine on va parler tennis chez toi
mais je compte sur toi non patrice
patrie je suis contente que tu sois là
ça m'aurait cette peine que notre porte
parole francesca on a vécu tellement de
choses à fabrice caron tunisie qu une
chamelle je te raconte aylin chamelle
est ce que j'aurais été obligé de lire
les noms des gens pour savoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis plus trop si tu elle si j'avais
été plus jeunes c'est pas parce que tu
es devenu la grande patronne que tu as
tout ce week-end le petit stagiaire et
ben écoute ça se négocie
[Applaudissements]